[Music]
fake meat is turning into real profit
grocery sales of all protein products
have just skyrocketed artificial meat
we're keeping all the good stuff and
trying to leave out the bad stuff it
will be the meat industry in 20 years it
got really popular really quickly and
then just as quickly lost all that
popularity and beyond meat get into the
downgrade today it's down about 70 over
the last six months it feels like beyond
meat for example didn't grow in the
right way it's an industry that promised
to essentially save the world and is
coming up short on that promise
yeah
my name is Dina Shanker and I'm a food
reporter on the consumer team for
Bloomberg I wrote about the plant-based
meat industry and its rise and
subsequent fall our story focused on the
two big companies that really created
the category and the demand for the
products Beyond me it was founded in
2009 and impossible foods which was
founded in 2011. both of these companies
were led by Founders that spent a lot of
time talking about the potential for
their products to do a lot of good in
the world the idea behind the company is
to provide a better form of meat right
to provide meat that provides all of the
delicious satiating experience that
we've come to love but does so in a way
that's healthy for your bodies and and
healthier for the Earth our mission is
to completely replace animals as a food
technology and the global food system by
developing better technology that not
only is vastly more sustainable and
healthier for the consumer but actually
more delicious for both of these
companies raising money was really
important and they raised a ton of it
the impossible raised more than 180
million dollars before they even sold a
single burger
now in 2019 a beyond meat went public
and it was a massive IPO Beyond Meats
maker of the plant-based meat-free meat
soaring more than 160 percent to become
the best IPO debut since the financial
crisis it was a big moment for the
entire industry not just for Beyond it
was starting to look more and more like
there could be this real audience even
from meat eaters our story makes the
case that fake meat is a fad and the
reason we think that is because it got
really popular really quickly and then
just as quickly lost all that popularity
it has found its most reliable consumer
base are people that don't eat meat
which is a very small portion of the
population and certainly not enough to
sustain a growth model what they really
needed was that flexitarian the people
that eat meat but are looking to cut
back and what we found is that meat
eaters do eat these products sometimes
but not with the kind of reliability and
regularity that would be required for
this category to really take off
impossible Foods took out an ad after
the story ran quoting some people from
Reddit that disagreed with the story
we're here at Michelle Darby's house in
Marlton New Jersey to talk about her
family's experience with plant-based
Meats
I started seeing like all of these
alternative products plant-based
products so I figured well why don't try
it and see if it's healthier because
that's what we thought Aidan what was
your favorite plant-based thing that we
had the impossible Burgers probably were
my favorite
foreign
2019 and 2020 sales have fallen at
supermarkets and at restaurants the
companies have seen their valuations or
their share prices uh just fall
dramatically and both Beyond and
impossible have had to do layoffs a few
factors have led to the decline of the
category the first is taste for meat
eaters the products just don't taste
good enough for them to be willing to
give up something they love like a
burger for a substitute that is also
more expensive which is another big
reason that the category is declining
the products just cost too much another
big reason is the health question the
first thing to keep in mind is that they
are Ultra processed foods I would say
across all disciplines and diet pattern
opinions Ultra processed foods are
considered a food we don't want to eat
that often everyone mostly believe that
we should be eating real foods that have
real ingredients and then there's been a
few kind of really productive studies
that have shown the difference between
people who eat Ultra processed foods
versus those who don't and the effects
on both weight and health outcomes so I
think the science and supporting it and
there's kind of generalized consensus
big part of why so many consumers moved
away from these products is a lot of
people want to be healthier
a lot of people tried these products for
that reason and for many of them they
discovered or their doctors told them or
they came to the inclusion themselves
that these were not healthier products
and that if they wanted to make
healthier changes in their life they
would have to look somewhere else
I went to a follow-up appointment at my
doctors and I said you know my weight
isn't changing at all I'm doing all
these healthy things with healthy foods
and
and they said well
still processed foods I guess it was
like an aha moment for me like why
didn't I even think of that I try not to
buy as much of it if it ends up being
like I don't know what these things are
I can't even pronounce them I tend to
not buy it
the really big claim that really does
stand up for these companies is that
their products are substantially better
for the environment than meat is and
that is absolutely true but that is not
a driving force in consumer Behavior at
this point at least when it comes to
food Animal Welfare is another place
that these companies are quite obviously
better than the meat companies but again
for a lot of people Animal Welfare just
is not a reason to change their food
behaviors
the idea that I'm eating plants and it's
better for the environment or you know
there are no animals involved like it
would have been more appealing so I miss
the fact that it wasn't what I thought
I do think food Innovation is incredible
and so it wouldn't surprise me that
there is a
a product out there that was able to use
um
I don't know some plant product and just
kind of pulverize it in a way that's
made a nice
Burger but the ones that have invented
an ingredient typically just fall under
that Ultra processed food
so if an ingredient was created in a lab
or not created by Nature it is an ultra
processed food
after the story ran the reaction came
quickly and loudly to say it's a fad is
frankly ridiculous I mean it you know an
eight billion dollar Global fad
I don't think so and when we look at our
repeats and our growth rates
we certainly don't think it's a fad that
said there are challenges that we have
to overcome I heard from a lot of people
in the food industry who told me that it
was right on and really encapsulated
what happened with fake me I also heard
from a lot of very vocal vegans and
vegetarians who told me I was wrong that
this was just a nascent industry at the
beginning of the technology and I would
be on the wrong side of History Jennifer
bartashus at Bloomberg intelligence
predicts that there could be one to two
percent growth in plant-based Meats in
the second half of 2023.
I think what we've learned is that meat
isn't going anywhere I also think
there's going to be a migration of these
products out of the fresh department
where they first launched where they
were going head-to-head with me and more
into the Frozen department where
products like veggie burgers have been
for years and years time will tell
whether this industry can make a
comeback and really live up to the
expectations that it's set for itself
thank you
[Music]
foreign